who was a dirtiest fighter you were
sulphide well I refer your Frye with
John Ruiz against Kirk Johnson the cake
Johnson kept hitting low blows and I
ended up disqualifying Kirk Johnson for
the heavyweight championship of the
world
you read also the knockout with
Mayweather and Ortiz right what happened
there we tell father protect yourselves
at all times
Larry's merchant said it best course
illegal sucker peg did you see that you
said hands down hardest punch it was it
Tyson that would you would say he's one
of them [ __ ] do you think UFC at all
would hurt the boxing business so listen
many people buy pay-per-view tickets to
watch a great fight some go to the fight
some buy $20,000 ringside tickets or
even $50,000 it's like a big heavyweight
matchup that's taking place but only one
person gets to be in the ring watching
it right there in front of them and
today we're sitting with a Hall of Fame
referee over a hundred and seventy title
fights that he refereed the one and only
Joe Cortez Joe day you think it's a
pleasure making the time to come down to
Dallas here with us over the pleasure
yes it's good to have you so I got a lot
of things I want to talk to you about
the future boxing I'm kind of seen right
now Oscar De La Hoya's almost becoming
the voice of boxing he's almost becoming
a Dana White of boxing cuz there's no
Don King today Don King on the boxing
side is de La Joya so I'm Kirsten of
what you think about the future box and
versus MMA and and some of the other
stuff I'm just curious out of my guy who
cuts my hair Michael rapattoni is from
Philadelphia was a boxer before he the
guy cut my hair because your hair - yeah
same guy so he cuts my hair I said
Michael I'm sitting with Joey Cortez
what questions would you want to ask
he said Pat the first question who's the
dirtiest fighter he ever saw fights so
I'm gonna open it up with that who was a
dirtiest fighter you were so fired
well I refer a fight with John Ruiz
against Kirk Johnson ok Johnson kept
hitting low blows I kept telling one of
him several times I had to start taking
action I start taking points I took a
point early part of fight took another
point in second part of the fight and he
kept hitting lower I kept going into the
course at least
one more low blow you're gonna be
disqualified it was a nasty fight yeah
and I ended up disqualifying Kurt
Johnson for the heavyweight championship
of the world which is something you
don't want to see him boxing cut people
pay money to see a good match and we
have to disqualify a fighter that's
that's really bad Donnelly for the
fighters but fans for the family
Elisabetta
was he a dirty fighter was it just that
day when he was fighting well I was a
was probably that day I think he was
getting beat up and he put looking for a
way out
gonna figure but let the referee get me
out of here and disqualify me your story
is a great story because you started off
as a boxer yourself Golden Gloves I
think 60 in 1962 and then you turn pro
at 1863 your 10 and 1 and your career
with a lot of fights that you had and
then one day you decided to be a referee
how did that happen how did you one day
say I just want to go out there and be
referee after I got married I went to
Puerto Rico for years if I got married I
started working at El Conquistador hotel
that was work out the hotel I worked my
way up the ranks and eventually I became
assistant manager at the hotel just
gentleman by the name of Pat masiha who
was a policeman in New York who was also
a referee in the amateurs what happened
to her freed my face when I wanted to go
on the Golf Championships along with my
brother Mike in Madison Square Garden he
was a guest at the hotel he ran into me
and he's one of plenty to see when I
moved back to New York in 76 at the end
of 76 I gave him a call he said Pat I'm
here in New York maybe we call for lunch
geez I want to talk to you I want you to
become a referee in the amateurs so he
planted a seed that's how it all started
i referee the amateur Police Athletic
League then the Golden Gloves six months
later I get called from the New York
State Athletic Commission a gentleman by
the name of a Frank Morris Deputy
Commissioner and he said Joe I want you
to turn pro I want to be doing this for
six months he says I know but we want to
work with you and get you rolling
normally at the referee three to five
years in the amateurs before even
consider going pro there so I had some
some talent and they they work with me
and five years later I'm doing my first
World Championship I haven't prior I
guess begun mantilla unbelievable back
quickly yeah yeah so I was on my way to
becoming a household name and very
honored that I got to make it to do the
major fights so let me ask you were you
when you refereed Mike Tyson was that
before no that was after I'd you were
already a pro referee when
you referee because Mike was fit was he
15 to fight that you referee the Olympic
fight there no no I never fear at Tyson
you had a third referee on that until he
when he turned pro that's what I referee
Mike Tyson so you have been in the ring
with Mike as a referee died types 9
times yes how was that watching him well
you know you know he's he's an animal in
there he's a devastating puncher we
either had he had the speed for
heavyweight he had unbelievable speed
and tremendous power with his punches
and every time he hit these guys with a
punch you know they were very very hard
blows and and I was new acceptable so do
you guys get quote one of these punches
they're gonna go and most of them did go
down with the exception of James quick
Tillis was the first fighter after 15
straight knockouts on my tension hat
however every 215 fight you want a
decision but he had some difficulties
that I thought I said to myself then I
might actually gonna have some problems
with tall good skillful boxers from the
outside and that's what happened when he
fought Buster Douglas Wow he had
difficulties when you saw that coming ah
see that's what come upon when he was
starting out who you saw witness
yourself because you who have you seen
fight I mean you've seen a lot of people
heavyweights you seen Foreman I've seen
everybody however you for me four times
okay Lennox Lewis about three times
Riddick Bowe ready both Holyfield yeah
never afraid most sort of heavyweights
in the last you know thirty years and
you also saw Canelo with Chavez Julio
Cesar Chavez with Oscar De La Hoya that
was a big one back in 95 who did you see
that you said hands-down hardest punch
it was it Tyson that what you would say
he's one of them yes is there one that
you would say hardest ever that you saw
personally yourself yes you right there
yes look at the top he was on the top
and then as a as a lighter fighter
I went to Julian Jackson who was a
middle way he knocked out a 48 of 56 of
his opponents so he was a good heavy
punch as a middleweight
how do you use are you entertained by
the fight yourself like are you
entertain my boxing yourself or no no
when you're working you don't work in a
job so you don't get to really enjoy it
you know you have to yes do your job for
is it for most the safety of the
fighters in the second of all is
enforcing the rules so at the first ten
years of my careers of referee I was a
scoring official they had three judges
and the referee was the third judge as
well so I had you know I had
to judge a referee the five watch out
for the savior of fighters so it was you
know multitask but some referees cannot
do all correctly a hundred percent sure
so there were some fighters that were
getting hurt like when boom boom Mancini
killed deuk-gu kim then they changed
from fifteen rods to twelve rails that
they took this corner wait for the
referee the referee could focus war and
the safety of fire that's a good
decision they made a good decision
because it was to help the fighters make
sure that they didn't receive
unnecessary punishment so how do you
mentally get yourself in a state to not
be in the fight where you want like it's
just purely rules how do you do that
well you have to think like an official
you can't think like a fan as a big
difference like a doctor doctors they're
going to in to surgery day they they
gotta be focusing only on a one patient
and only on one day you don't have
somebody you like more than the other
guy like is it you know like if your
favorite fighters of all time could you
say your favorite fighters of all time
no no not when you're active are free I
can't I try to stay away from that
because you have to be is like fine line
we came to be cold almost to do yes
evangelist exactly you have to be
because you have to be fair with the
fighters you can't wear the Bell starts
they gotta have even playing field like
I'll take off together so you have to
kind of like don't pick sides when you
call it you could do Oscar De La Hoya
against Joe palooka you can't favor
Oscar the lawyer because he's a favorite
name I look a fighter a fighter beat but
they took off that Bell to give it they
turned I built over to the official in
the ring they give it to the Commission
that means that the judges should be
looking at fighter a and B not looking
at a champion is oh it's purely on the
professional standpoint so who as your
referee
you've seen so he said hardest puncher
ISA Tyson and in middle wait you said
someone else Joe Jackson so now who was
the fastest you watch who would like
right in front of you watching these
guys fight who was the quickest you know
footwork hands well sugar Elena was one
I had a lot of footwork Hector macho
Camacho us another he was also
entertaining yeah yeah yeah very
charismatic individuals in the ring they
can move around pretty good that great
speed there's a fight enough time
helping out I'm a consultant with them
Devon Haney
who's fighting on next Friday on
Showtime the main event he's a kind of
Friday
you can't Holly hit him he has a
nineteen and old record and there were
fourteen knockout Devon Haney some of
the Mayweather like Mayweather as far
happens but his father's training this
kid to Mayweather's father's training
he's training to Devon
he's in Vegas yeah he yeah he's from
Oakland California and he's a great
fighter believe me I say that this kid
gonna go places in boxing you think so
he he can't Holly touch him he has a
good ring mechanics
he's got good reflexes timing you can
punch he's all around discs a hazard or
even mayweather said it that's the next
rising star in boxing so today if you
are gone you're retired your last fight
was Canelo vs. door I need your tie back
in 2012 when you retired so today you've
been away from it when you go back any
of history you've been in this industry
for a long time for decades five days
five decades right exactly so what who
do you say now like this this is my
favorite fighter of all time or these
are the greatest fighters of all time do
you have that now yes I look back now I
said Muhammad Ali was one I never Afridi
was one of them Roberto Duran or you put
the ring on it yeah oh yeah absolutely
everybody in boxing know that Roberto
Torres one of the greatest of all times
it's a lightweight and you have a cool
accessory Chavez was a great one Oscar
De La Hoya was an outstanding fighter
Manny Pacquiao why referee about four
times he's an Australian fighter I mean
Mike Tyson absolutely he's in that mix
as well would you put Mayweather
another's as a top five yeah he had
proven himself you know what so many
championship held the titles for over 19
years consecutive years war fighter has
done that none so for his weight class
would you say the greatest of all time
for his weight class since he's never
been beat no I would not say the
greatest really tell me why though
because I felt like Sugar Ray Robinson
was the greatest 147th and he went to
middle way but they're better fighters
I've been outstanding I mean should
weigh Leonard if you compare both him
and Mayweather I would say that she
really had more ability more in
mechanics and he has so many more
different techniques in Orinda and Floyd
Mayweather Mayweather was a good fighter
excellent good defense he was a fighter
that hit and didn't get hit but you
watch the sugar where lenders fights
with with her is and with Marvin Hagler
today you can watch them on YouTube
every day yeah very entertaining fights
yeah some by the way didn't you you
refereed also the the controversial
fight right the knockout with Mayweather
and
the crazies right we're at the end your
T's head Bob you know headbutt it and
then came back what happened there well
what happened there was a ortiz head but
it may
whether intentionally so I took a point
as I took a second you didn't do it
intentionally but when you look at the
camera you can see it was intentional
you know a matter of fact he did he
tried to do something earlier in the
fight and I warned him about it but this
time he cut Mayweather so I had to stop
it give him the warning that I took a
point then he hugged me whether was he
kissed him on the cheek and then he
hugged him again the second time and as
I looked at - thank you but to make sure
he saw me when I get to see those time
was in yeah and I looked at the
timekeeper because Mayweather was
blocking me so I looked at the
timekeeper he went like this and next
thing I know Mayweather or she went to
hug him again the third time and maybe
when I just clocked him because I
already called time in we tell fighters
protect yourselves at all time and
that's just what happened he dropped his
guards and made what it took advantage
of it Larry Merchant said it best it was
a legal sucker punch look that legal
sucker punch yeah I remember watching a
fight I was I was watching the fight
life and I'm saying wait a minute what
just happened here right right but even
after the first left he took he's still
looking at you yes at least after the
left has some reflexes to move I don't
know why he didn't move he looked at me
like I said Jame hit me with a punch and
they came to right hand and doctor Bible
you know what what time is in you don't
you don't be hugging and kissing the
guys a third time yeah I didn't
understand what I didn't understand is a
following I don't think if the one that
was a sucker punch was the first punch
not the second punch because the first
punch came in and then Mayweather didn't
go boom-boom
Mayweather hit the left and then he
backed up and Ortiz is looking at you
then hit the second I'm like at least
put your you aren't you know hands up
protector so he was he goes to the
concussive episode at that moment we
gave with a left foot he was ready
understand what there but not there in a
better way Victor Ortiz did tell me
afterwards and we had lunch together
dinners together many times after that I
said Joe my corner told me to head but
Mayweather intentionally he said I never
done that you not like my style but they
wanted me to do that to stop the
momentum and he says I got rid of the
whole Tim Monroe with him he said I
apologize what happened that night
historically was he known as being dirty
or not never he wasn't me I remember
anything yeah that was kind of weird
when you saw that yeah what fight is he
fighting that they going back to Chavez
I mean when you hear people talk about
Chavez as a boxer it's a whole different
conversation the amount of fights he had
I
no how many people during his era fought
as much as he fought he was fighting
every two three months he was not
turning down any fights what made him so
special well there's only one who has
HIV he definitely is one of the great
was in the history of boxing he had good
Reema Kanaka puncher could take a good
punch
he had a great defense as well he was
just one of those special guys that knew
how to work the body worked ahead he
figures you killed a body the head dies
you know he would have good devastating
left hook to the to the liver which is
what won his trademark punches and he
was definitely an outstanding fighter it
just seems to have it all you look at
certain suppose you find certain boys
athletes that have something different
anybody else it was so different about
him is he had it all he had it all yeah
and then Duran because I know a lot of
times when you hear Tyson talk about
boxers he always goes back to Durant
yeah he's always like given so much love
and credit to Duran and Ali always but
what made him so special devices skills
he had I mean he almost came out a mark
at all fights for the exception of the
one I referee were him and Oscar De La
Hoya the first time when he got cut but
a hard jab and Duran or is this know
about director Aaron the Reyes
Australian because he had a killer
instinct he had a look in his eyes he
was always focused and always know how
to cut corners cut you down had a court
combination he was great counter puncher
good body punch a good head punch it and
he had all the footwork that he had was
unbelievable his feet he had for a
lightweight he was like wait
welterweight super welterweight and
middleweight champion he was division
four insane exactly and I remember
referee in his last title fight that he
won against Iran Berkeley in 89 with
which I think was one of the best fights
I have ever referee about 27 world title
fight Roberto Duran Iran Berkeley
Berkeley losses middleweight title
I guess supposedly a washed-up fighter
the rain came by that night like he was
a young fighter it took the middleweight
championship you know poster Leonard
that the fight that we had the Sugar Ray
Leonard I think he got the 10 million
dollar purse it was a number like around
the 10 million dollars and he came back
to Panama I've been to his restaurant
when I went to Panama you know him and
his wife are always there themselves hey
he's always dancing with his wife but
when you go there when you go back to
that era if he didn't lose his
discipline and
stayed strong and didn't put on the
weight how long do you think he could
have gone he kind of got at least
another five more years
he was peace party a lot it's not doing
drugs and drinking and they have the
world by their fingers he could have got
at least another got five more years
because he was always in great shape at
the first part of his career the second
part he started fading when he did that
No Mas fight against Sugar Ray Leonard
people said what the hell happened there
you never seen his life try to just walk
away a bit of a row we're not taking a
punch
easy got disgusted and just couldn't hit
the couldn't deal with shooter lenders
tactics yeah and disrespect he said you
know what I'm out of here and that was
in the No Mas fight you think that hurt
his legacy or do you think the boxing
people who know the world of boxing
still put him as one of the great ones
well I think it tarnishes guys career to
some extent because people always
remember that one yeah the way movies
about yeah memories about there's all
this stuff about yeah but he was
definitely well it circles out one of
the greatest in the lightweight division
how much like you know a lot of time
people ask me questions about
entrepreneurship and business and they
say oh my gosh look at this guy you know
and I've been the world of sales for a
while and I saw a lot of guys coming
going I would see you guys like this
girl's gonna kill it she's so amazing
tenacious look at him he's so amazing at
the way he talks and communicates but
then there was bad habits that they had
on the side how often you saw guys
coming up where you said this guy could
be the future Hall of for me it could be
one of the best ones that we've ever
seen and then they took a wrong route
and made a mistake in and boom tarnish
their entire career how often did you
sit on your world I saw quite often
that's what what a big name like Mike
Tyson with one of the great was he in
tough admits and he showed that he does
the undisputed truth talk show that he
does
it's ashamed I see a fighter like him we
had all the talent in the world and he
was just when he went to Japan to fight
Buster Douglas he was hanging around
with girls and doing drugs in Japan he
just went crazy and he loses a title and
that was from that time on all the
fighters said okay you know my talent
exposed himself he could be taken and he
was you know I mean I even his last
fight that I referee against Kevin
McBride
in DC I had to stop to fight Mike Tyson
he was fighting knocked his kid out but
my tyson wasn't was none no condition to
I got a nobody even heard of Kevin
McBride I had to stop to fly at the end
of the sixth round
my taxi just couldn't deal what he was
so fatigued nothing he was taking a
pounding but he just couldn't deal with
it no more and his heyday he would like
this guy out of war oh oh yes so do you
think that's common in the world of
boxing yes a lot of fighters why do you
think dad uneducated
yeah educated they're not trained
properly dad don't you need a good
leader somebody a good role model to
keep on the right track but when you
make it to the top level in your career
you're fighting the big names you're
coming out of poverty living almost
industry think also all the sudden you
get ten million dollars yeah and you
guys extend million-dollar buy homes the
best cars in the world everything before
the north just trapped out I get bumped
off for the fight to fight on the mat
then I'm making a million dollar fight
anymore now they they lose our homes
like my Isis lost home because you have
the money to pay for the taxes hey you
don't know how to manage your money's I
think they need to be educated a little
bit more with this kind of money I think
that's one of the reasons why they
respect all the brawn so much in the
world of MBA because this is a guy that
grew up without a father figure didn't
go to school the argument with him an MJ
MJ went to Carolina he had a Dean Smith
or Kobe had a father that played in the
NBA and LeBron comes in without anything
and he stays so disciplined all this
money being given to him and you see
that in all sports but in boxing
especially I was just curious what you
thought about it let me ask you
historically when you think about boxing
what if you were to say these five
events or characters help the world of
boxing who would you say they would be
hypothetically like the movie Rocky did
had helped the franchise of boxing if
you were to say few names a handful of
names who would you say those names were
B got to say Sugar Ray Allen it was one
of them because when he became Olympic
champion I mean he was a household name
Oscar De La Hoya another Olympic
champion what did they do they change
the game they inspired other notable
great talent to the sport even a Roberto
durán I mean he came out of nowhere from
poverty became one of the best fighters
out there I mean you guys will sell out
arenas I mean they were really
outstanding fighters who listen say
Chavez ever free him against Greg Hogan
Mexico City a spec of Satan 136 thousand
fans short of the large crowd in boxing
history
people say Honda needs one individual
howdy-howdy was able to sell out a
stadium like that what was so special
about this fight is not their handful of
them that really turned boxing around
and of course Floyd Mayweather is one of
them is
well I'm he's the first athlete to ever
make a billion dollars in in the sport
of boxing Oh any sports so yes I have
full of good fighters that make you turn
the whole boxing around my Tyson was one
also he will sell out any arena because
of his punching power how much of a do
you think is promotional how much of it
we do you think is abilities you
showmanship is what I got to have good
showmanship but you also got to have
good promoters behind you a good
marketing team the promoters are
important because a little salt a fight
right in their dress you have to you
have to sell your fight your show if you
want to be successful you need a good
marketing and promotion promotional team
behind you you cannot do it by yourself
you win though Conor McGregor when he
for Mayweather he was pretty good
showman himself he promoted in a big way
in a big way and I remember they called
me the trainer my training for five
weeks on the rules on boxes so I well he
was firing I'll be in the ring with him
and giving him instruction making sure
he did the right thing he will look
halfway decent in the ring against Floyd
Mayweather
he lasted 10 rounds you know that's
another guy that was able to showmanship
and of course Muhammad Ali great you
know he was a good talker and he
performed any and he came across with
Conor when you were working with them
for five weeks which by the brilliant
move on his hand for him to want to
bring somebody like you so you can teach
him what to do because he kept hitting
there Mayweather in the back of the head
every time that we don't know if you cut
that what that private I want to do that
took points from me doing training you
were doing that to me yeah I would take
point I said you can't do this you know
but when Nene in the healing a battle
you know they kind of forget about Saul
Robert Byrd the referee
before the fire said make sure you watch
out for the punches that he'll actually
hit behind the head or you said that I
told the referee if we can't watch out
for that because I've been training with
him I said so try and interesting
don't take any nonsense from him when
you start pulling down yeah if you got
take poised take points away why don't
right away to take control I thought he
was gonna kick I thought I was gonna
expect the King to cat I'm like if he
kicks mayweather something's gonna
happen yeah we be disqualified you know
yeah they be done were you there when
him and Paulie were going at it or yes
what happened what really happened I was
more of a bobble pushed in anything I'll
push a punch and a push at the same time
so I would have said no knock down
because there was not a real solid knock
down so you wouldn't have know because I
know Paulie confronted you have to were
these
don't say anything say nothing because I
found a copy in each confidentiality
agreement prior to that time yes I
couldn't talk did you ever talk to
Paulie about it afterwards or no so he
knows like I wasn't yeah so so let me
ask you this when you were watching them
go at it cuz paulie's pretty legitimate
boxer he was suicide world champion he
came in a with that little condition to
be Safari I mean he was so you could see
was flabby he was not enough okay I've
flown in from New York overnight on it
the next afternoon he's fine with when
they were sparring did you think
mayweather could hang with him or no I
thought that not made with I'm sorry
Conor McGregor at the beginning knobbed
at the end I've said you know I think he
can he can hang with Mayweather for a
couple of rounds I was surprised that
everyone's hair runs sure you were not
expecting for it to go 10 rounds that
type Ib stop about the fifth or the
sixth but I knew that McGregor was
dangerous enough to maybe hurt
Mayweather in the first couple of rounds
because he had a good punching power
he was so awkward that he can catch me
whether he almost caught him with a good
shot in in the first early rounds I mean
the judges Autry judges game but Gregg
got in the first three or four rounds
yeah he got one left and the uppercut he
got in yeah and you saw Mayweather back
up you're like wait a minute
it could get something in there that was
a punch I was saying if he catches
Mayweather was surprised partially I
thought he could put me well you never
know
of course I mean sometimes punching you
don't see coming as what to hurt you
that's right and and that guy is that
unorthodox when you play poker and you
stay out sit at a table if you and I
have been playing for 10 years you know
my style I know your style you're a
conservative Sam always aggressive where
I tilt faster but you know my style you
can't tell when a new guy comes in
because you don't know his style you
don't have a lot of transactions so
Mayweather doesn't know how to fight
against together yeah do you think
Connors still gonna have a career in
boxing or no you're not gonna come back
human not even our career and me anymore
yeah any stop with that guy could be Pat
a Russian kid yeah that's right what do
you think about the could be guy well I
think he's dangerous you bureau for a
while can he come switch we're not no
he'll make a mistake like McGregor did
if he does yeah but it could there it's
just like the other danger pan Camaro
that when mayweather for that que pasa
million undisputed champion and
mayweather put him away as you think the
person well you know it was a joke you
know it was I mean this kid
never box it in his life--and and
mayweather just still I'm even don't
make wasn't retired but he still had the
skills you know he still has a little
spark of the old flash yeah when I watch
it I'm like you know this almost looks
like it's they're doing a publicity
stunt for a movie it didn't make any
sense to me well the fans were there
Mayweather edited a cell to give these
guys mayweather like 9 million dollars
to for two and a half minutes you know
to fight again I never fought in his
life I would say go I'll take him on to
you know for that kind of money of
course a web browser in Vegas but for 10
million dollars last month I paid him
off so this house it's painful ready
this house is sponsored by Japan right
oh so going back to the promotional side
you were talking about best promoters of
all time obviously let you say Don
King's on that list who else would you
put on that list are Arum
hasta la jolla got it those are the
three yeah you would put that on her on
that list absolutely oh wow
interesting here would you put Dana
White as the promoters what would you
put him in a category like that but not
a boxer he's a he's not but as a
promoter into a bonus it may may yes
he's definitely the best he would be in
there yeah okay so let's talk a little
bit about the comparisons of UFC and
boxing do you think UFC at all will give
a threat to boxing and hurt the boxing
business absolutely not absolutely not
no tell me why because boxing is a sweet
science of boxing and maymays my
schoolyard fighting there's a big
difference I mean this is boxing this
box that will you see boxing these guys
it's like a chess game do you guys are
really thinking the game out real real
real smart a boxer does it was and may
make you can't guys MMA
eight nine fights they find it for a
championship there's still a little
green you can't compare these guys with
foot box that's why I'm a make guys are
going to boxing they can't seem to make
it because boxer disc fighters are so
skilled much more skilled of ring
mechanics you know defense and speed and
that's a different kind of a training if
a new generation is great for them the
younger generation 40% of the fans are
females and maymay and that's good I
mean it's good for MMA because and
useful it's just been around like 12 13
15 years almost they're killing boxing
been there for 100 years you know yeah
but then boxing is still going strong
exuse the best pay-per-views in combat
sports is boxing so you don't think
boxing is gonna be like Sears and Sears
goes out of business and Walmart's puts
them out you know I don't think it's
gonna because Sears has been around for
18 so was a sick HBO was around for 45
years yeah they dropped out but I don't
think it because a lack of competition
because a lack of interest it because
financially they were not making that
number I didn't ever either invest
everybody into movies that rather than
this for us we have had some former
mobsters on the channel before and we've
interviewed them sometimes when I asked
them I said so talk about gambling and
they would talk about what gambling in
the 80s it was very easy to go and fix
games and basketball or college bets
because they needed money but you'll
also hear what they'll say about boxing
back in the old days back in the old
days and so for me I'll give you an idea
for me look I'll watch boxing matches
sometimes and I'll sit then I'll say
there is no way in the world that guy
won no way it's a drunk no way or he won
on the scorecard seven to five how are
they given him eight to four SATA triple
G fight vs. Canelo the first fight I
don't know if you yeah remember that
fight did you give that to Canelo did
you give that fight as a draw - no give
it to triple G that's why after watching
it carefully I gave it to triple G by
two round seven to five so you know the
referee that give it like a lopsided it
was a judge judge judge you had the
judge that sometimes for me as a sport
as a fan forget about being in the world
I'm not in the business I'm not and
we're not watching I'm like you know
what I don't know I mean if I'm if I'm a
money guy and a finely gambler and if
I'm in that world and if I'm a mob guy
I'm a power guy okay
and there's a lot there so people like
that or on money people still around you
know if I say you know go to draw hey
you know judge this is what we're gonna
do some of this stuff you know the dirty
side of boxing you hear a lot of people
talk about and it loses some people and
then you go to UFC you're like listen
someone's gonna get knocked out here's
what's gonna happen with the someone's
gonna get knocked out because this is
like a fight and it's very obvious it's
a lot easier to be able to tell who won
and who didn't win versus boxing it's
just because one judge goes out there
and says this you're sitting there
saying wait a minute what happened over
here how much do you think the integrity
of the game is still there in boxing
today well you know people get turned
off too bad controversial decisions a
labor happens to be one of the best
judges in
that's why she was useful for so many
world championship fights her husband
Robert Byrd is also a referee he was in
the Marines he was a police captain in
the police in LA a very respectable
family she yet had off night then again
I was talking to one of your men last
night Mario we're talking about
positioning of the judges
I totally disagree with the position of
the judges today because of the angles
when the fighters are they're blocking
the time punches something you don't
have a punch landed or not that's why
that judges at three different sides of
the Ring they'll see different different
punches that are being landed where
these three judges saw the punch die
judge didn't see it then finally go
another way in two angles they miss it
up until recently I did a study and I
changed position of the judges I put
three on top higher height ladders and
three on the bottle yes to see and I got
into the ring with two fighters and I
gave him clickers I said I want you to
click on a punch of seroma you don't
know do this how recent was I did about
four years ago and I did the study and
it proved that from the top the most
they were miss per round by judge was
one to two punches per round
they were miss on the top when the
bottom I were as a judges how many
punches do you miss anywheres from 9 to
19 punches per round per judge so then I
would change the judges from the one
downstairs I googled motions for four
rounds we did this and it was the same
result every run the most of strange
they were miss was two punches at the
bottom always
9 to 19 points per round so I said we
gotta change the position of the judges
raising them up a little higher you can
see better that's why at home the
viewers get a better view of to fight
the punches that are being landed
compared to the judges live like in
tennis you got the empire's the referees
on tennis they're sitting up high
looking down gotta can see the lines
better otherwise they want to hit him on
the low level so I said in boxing and
they would have raised him up from the
beginning they can see you know the
punches landing every magazine I said
give me a little column on it the guy
looked love my they say John is the most
simplest but most ingenious idea I've
ever seen I said this is amazing he gave
me four pages and I proved it with
photos for the punches are taken from
the different angles from here and a
photo from up here how here you can see
it to punch two fighters in landing down
here or you see at the back of a fighter
it was simple but people said no the
judges you know they whatever you put up
there and interfere with the view the
fans
I told create a electronic type of a a
chair like an empire the tennis make an
acrylic when we were 19 filled the views
of the fans but they will complaint
Mauricio Suleiman the president World
Boxing Council said I like the concept
we're gonna do it in Mexico we're gonna
start with the preliminary fights and
we'll do the acrylic chair to see how
that goes
I'm still waiting for that to happen
when is that in Mexico when what that
was last year but they didn't do it
nothing yet baguette people still a
little hesitant so let me ask you to
make change agreed that even yourself
when a fans say I don't think the
decision I don't agree with the decision
you also agreed that they have to make
some changes or else they're not getting
the right judging being done today
exactly I still think that I've been in
boxing so long I think I think out the
box a lot of folks yes don't don't think
that way I've been in interim boxing so
long I look to see I leave no stones
unturned when it comes to anything for
the betterment of the sport so I'm
always looking to see what can I do to
improve and that's one area that didn't
need some help I would say I know the
judges I know that they're not corrupt I
know that I'll undertake it just that
where they're sitting the position is
not where they should be sitting there
I'm there from the beginning with his
first title boxing of a hundred years
ago they put him in their own position
they should have been a pion on here
it's very hard to trust the fight I
trust the sport well it's because you
can't you can't score what you don't see
as a fan you know when you watch
basketball what happens hey here's a
score here's how it ends here's what
happened great football very simple
these are the rules this is what you're
doing and now they're doing instant
replay you know the whole thing that
they had would instant replay so was
this a pie that he stepped in like
recently there was a game with you
Cowboys the receiver Kent comes down
gets the ball and they called it yeah it
is a touchdown initially they didn't
call it a touchdown and then they end up
winning a game and so I think the boxing
side I don't know when I watch it every
single time I watch it literally every
single time I watch the boxing match I
think about that today
well the time I don't know if I trust it
well I think it will change the
precision of the judges that you
associate what there is a big difference
now now you gonna see is very
comfortable what other changes you think
they need to make you said there's a lot
well Bob train better training for the
footage
just add for the referees if you don't
work that often you know stay sharp yeah
you gotta be working on a regular basis
yeah can't work once every two it's
every three or six months
you gotta work like almost every month
like I did two in Vegas the least amount
of judges you have the more they're
gonna work from stage they have twenty
five thirty judges you're not a fan of
that you don't know I think that the
least you have the more they're gonna
work but everybody was to get a license
to be a judge or referee New York has
over thirty judges and I don't know
about twenty some of our referee hey
well as it is now that pay well that
means it's not a good paint job I mean
the most you're gonna make for
mayweather-pacquiao fight the most
you're gonna make it probably twenty
thousand dollars that's not big buddy
compared to the hundreds of millions
that you guys are making you know so and
as for edit fight yeah of course more
fun if you've made three or four
thousand dollars a lot preliminary
fights you're lucky if you make a couple
of hundred dollars get at it yeah
there's small fights you know - yeah
what was it six yes so how about
referees are referees making money no no
I'm saying are dying they're not they're
not money to be over free or judges
there's no big money it becoming judges
it's just a murder they do it because
they love of the sport they love of the
game
yeah you can't stop em there's nothing
you know about the love yeah I respect
the lovely it's not like NFL basally
yeah they get pensions and all our
boxing you're independent contractor
you're like nothing they don't take care
of you the way they show are you a fan
today or you do you look at her like a
fan today are you still looking at as an
analyst I know you're an analyst obvious
about it but I suppose I've been trained
so many years to be neutral so I look at
things very neutral still till today so
I try to be neutral but I also I use a
lot of common sense and I look at things
a little different than a regular fan
I'm messy things that you made you and
I'd be looking at a two fighters you may
see that they're equal I can see right
off the bat up fire the beetle and it's
not even close to the fighter
a as far as technique skills or whatever
I can see who's got the skills gonna
make it so who do you think is overly
promoted that's not as good as people
make them out to be
anybody out there right now there's a
bunch of fighters are coming up have
been proved us all like Anthony Joshua
heavyweight champion from United Kingdom
is the real deal yeah I don't know yet
you know I want to see him again at the
anti Walder then I could tell you that
he's a real deal
people already compared to Muhammad Ali
come on you know the guy is not a
household name yet in this
Heide cook compared to Muhammad Ali you
know he's got potentials but I don't
think he's ready at the level and not at
the level yes do you watch UFC as well
or not at all
not much no not at all you follow any of
it like that not really not really
really no I'm not really a MMA guy so
you're more the art than you are about
the actual yeah to manual yeah I try I
try to pick up a little because I would
I trade Conor McGregor for the
Mayweather fight I got a little bit more
into it I went to a couple events to
watch to see how it was it's okay you
know but they need a lot of work to be
done it doesn't do it for you no not yet
really it's not that I've been a boxing
man all my life so it's off for me too
so yeah I kind of like it to some extent
but I see that this to have so much more
to learn as far as being skillful in
Wrentham it's gonna be interesting
things got really serious with La Hoya
and Dana White it seems like it got
pretty serious III like to see De La
Hoya
getting a little bit involved with the
MMA you would I would like to see that
happen why why would you want because
there's a the new generation is a big
following there so you get a bigger
captive you're gonna have a good captive
audience you can happen MMA and boxing
are the same cards and you know you
people say it's a lot of MMA fans that
see this fighter said they didn't know
the younger generation take a hooked on
a fighters like you're saying cross
pollinating yeah exactly we're not
saying they are going to stay golden boy
and start his own oh no that would be
good against MMA against you have why
not why not so you wonder yeah if he if
you did so well in boxing yeah tell her
yeah why not try and make it something
is competitive I mean he likes
challenges you had the World Boxing
Council then you had the World Boxing
Association then you're the
International Boxing Federation then you
had the World Boxing organization for
major sanctioning bodies are out there
it doesn't mean because you have one
brand UFC out there doesn't mean that
that you somebody cannot come in and
start their own why not the more the
better you can let him compete we're
gonna compete best De La Hoya
are they in Hawaii who do you think I
think don't know why it's really good
for himself he's been established
already but Oscar the law has a big
following in boxing he could cross over
and throw a lot of friends into MMA just
because Oscar the lawyer is involved so
you think the La Hoya can do more
falling from boxing to MMA then they
know I can do from MMA - from UFC to
boxing absolutely yeah because kadala
has a bigger following he has a bit more
bit bigger name he has a lot of
credentials we had because he's been in
India himself the other way I'd ever
competed so are we gonna see the end of
this or is this is this feud gonna
continue between Dana White and De La
Hoya how do you look continue you know I
think it gonna be good I mean why not it
gonna keep the game alive we're gonna
keep a lot of people wondering why not
should they shouldn't they you know
it'll be great I'm actually very curious
to see what's gonna take place I'm very
curious to see what's gonna take place I
can take when I do like when I want to
buy people over to the house if I see
which one gets more draw of people
wanting to see it more people see you
have seen it they want to see box things
the only generation you're gonna get
that with the yellow generation the ball
baby there's baby boomers or middle age
that they're more interesting yeah it's
a good thing what you're saying then
that means eventually boxing is gonna go
away not gonna go away but new
generations coming up but I was why
Oscar De La Hoya is going both ways
because you know he said he feels that
he gotta tried to educate the MMA fans
that we got it and box it as well yeah
but then the other side they come back
and they'll say things like if there was
a street fight there's not a single
boxer that could hang with a UFC fighter
what do you think when my board by Greg
a 24 Bay weather yeah but you think
Mayweather could hang in the UFC ring
but kings I don't know kiss yeah that's
what takes it right some of these kicks
even this last fight with John Jones he
was having this fight with Gustav one
yeah and he was kicking in and all of a
sudden he was done I don't know if he
saw that fighter yeah yeah those kicks
or what changes the game half the time
you watch these guys fighting in boxing
no one's getting kicked so it's a lot
safer
I don't maybe whether it was saying
toying with the idea of yeah I'm gonna
go and UFC and I'm gonna do this I don't
see that ever happening without certain
rules that he'll create well there was
rule buddy for the Japanese kid the
other day yeah but the kick have a fight
away that woulda kicked
mayweather he would have gotten five
five million dollars if you woulda
kicked it with gone five million fine
five million dollars on the contract
that's how I think if Mayweather ever
does something he'll get in there
remember how early I asked you a
question I said what do you think were
some of the you know ideas or figures or
names that change the world of boxing
and Broadmoor
boats to it right you said Duran you
said Oscar De La Hoya
you said Robinson Robinson you said
Sugar Ray Robinson that brought a lot of
eyeballs to it do you think boxing needs
somebody that brings and inspires people
to be like oh my gosh like we have to
heavyweight man to people going against
each other because it's almost as if
Holyfield need a time as Tyson as much
as you know it's almost as if what made
the heavyweight exciting back in the
days is Ali needed Frasier Frasier
needed Ken Norton these guys were like
all needing do you think the fact that
there isn't a real competition to their
people like I don't really care to watch
boxing who's really gonna beat any of
these guys they're all boring when I
watch and we think that's what's missing
today yeah exactly that's what you know
the golden era bas it was when you a Ken
doll in Muhammad Ali Larry Holmes
he has so many great heavyweights out to
Joe Frazier the cold Muhammad Ali said
he wanted the greatest but you cannot be
the greatest unless you force somebody
that was really you need a good dance
partner you just can't make it on your
own become great because of competitive
competition you had so Ali was
critically we reformed Joe Frazier the
trilogy's that they had and you talk
about ready bow Evander Holyfield those
three fights that they have of whichever
for the first and the third
those are great fights legit you know
yeah yeah and you know you got a Manny
Pacquiao who for one minor Marquez there
for four times I remember I refer you
the first one where Marcus went down
three times in the first run anywhere
free and his planet would have stopped
it I saw something in Marquez I let it
continue and I stopped it there never
whatever fight two three and four so I
gave him a chance and he came back and
got a draw in that fight and it made a
couple of hundred million dollars
because I didn't stop the first fight
because you don't stop the first exactly
but you know but you know fighters out
there
you only become great when you fight
another great fighter that's what I'm
saying by the way I was at the last
Marcius fight with Pacquiao sitting next
to park his wife and his family right
and when you saw that punch you thought
the guy was
I mean you dead he was now he thought it
was that 30-second he was gone yeah wife
was in tears crime very interesting here
was I think the same goes with baseball
I don't know if you're a baseball going
if you're Puerto Rican I know Puerto
Ricans a lot of times they're in
baseball did you follow a lot of
baseball growing up work yes I did you
know Juan Gonzales was my favorite
player Juan Gonzales was a Puerto Rican
player okay
coming up but when major league baseball
went through strike in the middle of the
90s baseball was dying stadiums were
empty nothing really was taking place
and in one season 98 McGwire and Sammy
Sosa went back and forth right they
brought the whole thing back and
everybody wanted to see baseball yeah
the homerun Kings the whole thing yeah I
mean I was they want to get one in a
break right Roger Maris from the Yankees
yeah they wanted to break his record and
60 home runs 61 Babe Ruth had 60 years
61 and then I think so say it's 66 day
urine yeah why it's 70 or something like
that controversy about course drug
enhance yeah of course for both of them
but you know they saved the game they
saved baseball and and eyeballs came
back on again and people started
following baseball again but I think
boxing meets that and I don't think it
has it today well it's coming back you
know I'm just coming but you have a lot
of good young fighters that are coming
out what's the biggest matchup right in
a weight class that has a lot of talent
that or even playing field yeah a little
weight division in the welterweight
division welterweight division you have
Keith Thurman Shawn Porter all spends so
many young what ways out there in the
top six
you got Manny Pacquiao still in the mix
he's fighting adrian broder yeah he's
still fighting angry and broader so
Manny Pacquiao is still a name the name
is still there anybody was a fight Manny
Pacquiao and they gotta make a good
paycheck but Manny Pacquiao was supposed
to lose his last fight he ended up
knocking on Lucas Matthysse
margin Tina nobody thought I was gonna
happen including myself
I told but he was gonna stop Manny
Pacquiao it was the other way around and
when that happened yeah yeah but with
Manny Pacquiao at his peak vs.
Mayweather at his peak who wins
piqué piqué well you know Mayweather a
very good defensive fighter Pacquiao has
some good skills but he's a little wide
with his punches we still give it a mean
way yeah maybe whether he was Mayweather
were capitalized and the openings when
he may was an excellent counter puncher
but he may well still what it was at the
peak you know how earlier we were
talking about people are getting into
bad habits drugs and all that stuff you
said yes it's very common I said why do
you think that is and he said because of
education experience all that other
stuff who are some of the names in the
world of boxing that behind closed doors
if they get ahold of a box of good
things happens with them you know you
know what I'm saying like you know he's
working closely with such-and-such he is
working close because you know when
Tyson has mentor pass
the way then all of a sudden he was a
complete different guy like wait a
minute I saw an emotionally stable human
being all of a sudden who is this Mike
Tyson everything changed who are a
handful of names that were very good
behind closed doors to develop leaders
and build them up back in the old days
there was a lot of mentorship I mean the
trainer's were had to play the role down
over trainable roles of a father try to
keep these fighters on the right track a
lot of Fighters yet to be humble and
what's your side changing was I making
the money a big group of individuals
stopped following you and those are the
ones that's not taking you to parties I
introduced really beautiful girls before
then you know these girls probably set
up set them up with these guys to try to
get them to drink something and before
you know they put something in their
drink before you know there's some kind
of a drug they're not they're addicted
to a drug which is something very common
even individuals down it not into sports
it's happening a lot today these days
yes a movie called chasing the dragon
it's about drug addiction and once you
start doing a draw sometimes even the
first time you get addicted to it and
you're stuck and you can't get out of it
it happens to a lot of these fighters
either the alcohol under the combination
of alcohol and drugs by Tyson was one of
those even Oscar the lawyer he admitted
himself he'd been in rehab and he
continues kind of trying to get his life
together and I respect him for that
because I believe a second chances and
Oscar the lawyer is I love him it's a
good man you know I really think he's
somebody that's a very special for the
sport but you got all the fighters that
don't have the luxury of having somebody
that can help you Oscar thank God he
asked for he financially fit where he
can support his his care to keep him on
the right track and of course once
you're addicted to something you have to
maintain he's like a AAA you gotta keep
going to these meetings to keep yourself
something always focused because I do
fall off track you're gonna go back into
the pur habits again so drug addiction
is something that that can hurt anybody
from all walks of life so who are good
people who are good mentors on the
boxing world today well you need you
need a good trainers you got a Robert
Garcia who's Mackey Garcia's brother
he's why he's a good one is a bunch of
good trainers out there Freddy Roach was
another good one and that's what tons of
out there of individuals that train fire
but you need good management team I let
this Devin handy the fight I've talked
to you about that I'm popping on as a
consultant is the 18 and over
he's 18 you know 13 years of age his
father Bill Haney is it's a father
it's a trainer although with Floyd
Mayweather senior and you guys keep try
to keep that son in check what I
teaching them and what are you saying to
them what you're in the world I talked
to him myself and I tell Devon you're
gonna go places a path you probably will
be one of the better ones keep yourself
humble you don't get cocky
watch out with the drug watch out with
the girls people you hang around with
cuz they don't what I'm gonna bring you
down so if I gave him good advice I said
you know I did it myself I come from a
single-parent home and I maintain myself
on the right track
by knowing that if I kept myself on the
right track it was a chance of me making
it as a world champion I didn't make
anything back that's a world champion
but I said you can leave make it like I
did I became a world champion in life
and that's because I did the right
things always state the right way what
do we mind the girls so talk about the
girls what girls you know the beautiful
girls you know you're young and your
hormones kicked in and now you got money
and and you got to control it or it
could be hard but you know yeah I tell
them you know you have ten good years of
boxing and you wanna get yourself a
girlfriend you can't stop somebody from
have a girlfriend get married you know
but do it do it the right way you know
keep yourself focused and don't don't
let yourself go on the wrong track
because you see on the right track with
a beautiful young lady that you have
Shawn Porter can't marry a couple of
years ago and he was single up until he
was about 28 years old but he kept
myself on the right track finally got a
nice young lady and they got married
recently to have a little baby and then
and I talked to him I was also advising
him and with his team he's a world
champion right now 147 and I think Shawn
Porter is one of the toughest ones in
the welterweight division
but it's focusing it but you have to be
focused and not only in boxing but in
all walks of life you want to be
somebody special you got to maintain
your composure and learn to be humble
and yes always be focused on that just
because you have money doesn't mean that
you can control the world doesn't mean
that and you're gonna let your cars down
you have to maintain yourself you know
in the right way so you can say I gotta
keep focused so I can keep growing if I
keep my pace I'm gonna fall apart you
have to have a good solid fund
so that you can build off for it how did
you emotionally stay in place me I've
always been a humble and I always want
to help people out and I know by helping
people I had to be a role model and have
to try to not only in boxing but I could
talk to people from all over the world
I've been with three presidents talking
one-on-one like you and I are talking
right now I've been blessed with so many
things in life I have three beautiful
daughters I've been married for 53 years
and I've always keep trying to keep
myself on the right track by having a
good heart and always giving pay paying
it forward and it's not like you've had
I mean you've had some challenges you
faced with your daughter when she went
through and you guys call your daughter
you're the undisputed champion well I
want you talk about what happened what
she was involved in a car accident
twenty-one years ago she end up a
quadriplegic he was a car thief my wife
Sylvia you know one of the things that
uh that happened to her and you know to
this day she so says that don't worry
about me I'm okay she gets in her car
everyday she goes to the gym five days a
week she works out here she's a most
beautiful young lady we'll see I took
her recently to be j.lo she's a big fan
and I know J Lo's my daughter's really
she's focus 100% we would keeping a
family together we all live in Vegas and
you still with your wife this is my wife
my wife and I work with ESPN as a bokken
analyst I will show a fair but firm on
Facebook does every Mondays and if our
talk show and I do the Joe Cortez show
on Tuesday variety type of show showed I
wanna try to put together in Vegas on a
local TV how'd you come up with the fair
but firm I was doing an interview like
we're doing right now and I was watching
it the gentlemen I think it was it take
to be a good referee
I said well you have to be fair with the
fighter but by the same token you had to
be firm to take control now when I saw
the interview I said fair but firm I
might try that and in his [ __ ] yeah I'm
fair but for violence I think George
Foreman said you know one thing about
Joe is he's fair but far yeah and I
became a branding for you last series
years so the last thing we do is we call
this a speed round I'll give you a name
and tell me the first thing that comes
to your mind okay I give you name and
you tell me what comes from a Dana White
Way I'm a good for the sport of MMA does
a lot for the sport and the new
generation is definitely following us
see Tyson Tyson the most devastating
puncher
the history of boxing Tyson Fury has a
fury surprising defense offers surprise
me and I think he has potentials to go a
long ways in a heavyweight division
Paulie Malignaggi
he was a good fighter from Brooklyn New
York Italian descent skillful fighter
put a lot of boxing : Glove champion
he's a good commentator official to him
Don King Don King mr. Don King with all
the hair something like bite and he
bought him one of the best promoters in
boxing Muhammad Ali's Anthony Joshua
Anthony Joshua up-and-coming great
British heavyweight champion WBA IBF and
the WBO champion so he's somebody to
recommend heavyweight division kabi kabi
MMA he surprised mcgregor i stopping him
he has a great career in MMA George
Foster George Foster
he beat me back in 1963 sixth round
fight at Madison Square Garden a
decision that was kind of close but I
said the defeat you guys for instance I
was pocket I'm looking for about what a
rematch never you've never spoken to him
after that no I never saw wow that's
interesting triple G triple G is one of
the toughest middleweight champion up
until he for Canelo Alvarez you seen his
better days
he brought a lot to box I like to see
him fight Canelo Alvarez to settle the
score - Rob who do you think wins
I think Canelo will beat him again
easier ok 13 Canelo what do you say
about Canelo Alvarez was a superstar in
boxing today he brings a lot to boxing
as a good promotional team behind Oscar
De La Hoya at the Canelo is somebody to
reckon with for the next couple of years
I'll leave it at that I love that I love
the commentary the stories the
experiences you've had you know it's
always great to sit down with somebody
who has gone to the top of their field
no matter what that field is it doesn't
I don't care what industry or and it's
not easy to go to the top of any field
and be called the international being
invited to be in the International Hall
of Fame of boxing that's a very big deal
to be a part of and I appreciate you
coming out and being a guest today
watching this but are you on Twitter on
Instagram are you a social are you more
on Twitter about Twitter okay send us a
tweet after watching this interview let
us know what you took away from it and
any questions you got for them send a
question to him on Twitter his handle is
gonna be right here my handle is gonna
be right here if you haven't
drop to the channel click on the
subscribe button again thank you so much
for coming thank you very much somebody
tis a pleasure thank you okay